the art director on a motion picture has
a very important job he's the fellow who
spends 24 hours a day picking out the
furniture for the producers house most
of them of course do a great deal more
than that and now to present the awards
for art direction here are Angie
Dickinson and Richard Conte
the art director is the imaginative
genius who designs our sets adapts
location sites to the needs of the
screenplay and in general provides the
geography without which there can be no
motion picture as we know it
in short theists of the movies for the
cake is to the frosting those nominated
for best achievement in art direction
and set decoration for a black-and-white
production our career art direction by
health Herrera and Walter Tyler set
decoration by Sam comer and Arthur Kranz
the Diary of Anne Frank art direction by
Lyle our wheeler and George W Davis set
decoration by Walter M Scott and Stuart
a Reese the last angry man art direction
by Karl Anderson set decoration by
William Kiernan some like it hot art
direction by Ted Hayworth set decoration
by Edward G Boyle suddenly last summer
art direction by Oliver muscle and
William Kellner set decoration by
Scott's Lyman and the winner is the
Diary of Anne Frank
art direction Lyle are wheeler and
George W Davis set decoration Walter M
Scott and Stuart Avery's
those nominated for best achievement in
art direction and set declaration for a
color picture our bender art direction
by William a Horning and Edward cuff on
your set decoration by Hugh hunt the big
fisherman art direction by Jean de Cure
set decoration by Julia her own journey
to the Center of the Earth art direction
by Lila of wheeler France spatially and
Herman eight Blumenthal set decoration
by Walter M Scott and Joseph Kish North
by Northwest art direction by William a
Horning Robert Boyle and Meryl PI set
decoration by Henry Grace and Frank
McKelvey pillow-talk direction by
Richard H Riedel set decoration by
Russell a Gausman and Ruby our Levitt
and the winner is Ben Hur
you may Hornung and edward Carfagna set
decoration art direction i'm a thought
direction to set direction oh thank you
myself and i also would like to thank
Eddie evil and Paul for their great help
to hunt thank you thank you